kannst du mal die luft und damit herz
willkommen zu einer video leute ich weiß
einige von euch sind seit einiger seit
geraumer zeit mit einem gewissen entzug
unterwegs auf dieser plattform denn
ihnen fehlt ein gewisser kontern auf
meinem kanal dieser content wird heute
wieder kommt denn wie wir uns heute
wieder zum ersten mal so mindestens ein
oder zwei wochen seit längerer zeit eine
hilf mir folge anschauen
zu diesem feierlichen anlass habe ich
mir selbst erstaunlich was besonderes
rausgesucht leute die folge jeweils 23
zu werden heißt frau betrügen für
knackarsch ja ok ausgangsszenario
etablieren also das ist das ehepaar das
sind die eltern von einem mädchen namens
lisa die beschreibung ist dass das
verhältnis von lisas eltern unter fühlt
ist und im bett lag schon lange nichts
mehr alles klar
gut muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen bei der
frisur hätte ich hätte ich ja auch mal
gar nichts das ist diese glauben ja also
ich will ich will nicht freundin liebe
mutter von liza aber was denkst du dir
denn so was ist was ist da
schiefgelaufen daraus noch deutlicher
machen die springst du hast richtig
mundgeruch
ja ich bin also off freund unterwegs ob
überhaupt kannte ja er sollte man in der
form natürlich in der ehe jetzt nicht
unbedingt machen ernte japan statt zu
sagen woran es wirklich liegt nämlich in
diesem farbton
ja das sieht aus wie das was ich was für
eine farbe ist aubergine ein cookie
verweisen spielwiederholung das nicht
viel zu tun du stinkst versteht mich
doch einfach mal leute das hat nichts
mit viel zu tun es hat es hat nichts mit
uns zu tun okay wir nichts dergleichen
von euch hören wenn ein ehepaar was eine
familie zusammen gegründet hat was
zusammen ein kind übrigens hier sichtbar
lisa hat wenn da der mann die
morgendlichen kontaktsuche seiner frau
ablehnt mit den worten du alte
schabracke du stinkst wie eine
mülldeponie aus dem mund dann hat das
nichts mit viel zu tun verstehen doch
einfach ja okay also er ist auf jeden
fall dieser typ von der vater von liza
ist der der seine frau betrügen wird ja
woche wieder jemand mit knapp das ist
sehr belastend für die tochter wenn sie
mitbekommt wie ihre eltern sich streiten
zum einen ist es ein thema das auch
belastend ist das einfach da kein
bertram da ist also noch fand aber
schauen wir nicht schlafen auf dem boden
ich habe bis der bis dato nur auf dem
boden geschlafen wenn ich irgendwie in
der neuen wohnung waren doch kein bett
da hatte die wollen ja scheinbar schon
länger da drin also da sollte man
vielleicht darüber nachdenken
und wo sind wir bei youtube kaka da sind
wir über helfen ja wir haben 31.000
schulden also also nicht euro schön
31.000 schulden dass das mal eine ansage
da würde ich aber auch natürlich auch
mal ne zahnhygiene vernachlässigen es
soll weiter bei acht mal ganz kurze
pause an der stelle
unabhängig von der diskussion jetzt
gerade hier läuft wie 31.000 schulden
zustande gekommen sind wir darüber reden
dass die frau einfach so 15 jahre älter
ist als er ist
oder er ist vielleicht so 30 130
bestimmt ja weiß weiß ja okay ich nicht
mehr so nicht freunden also man sieht
dass jemand sehen sein aber so mitte
vierzig könnte schon sein danach denken
wir dass noch weitere leute das würde
heißen als sie gerade 18 wurde und ihren
führerschein gemacht hat und selbst
verträge unterschreiben durfte war er
drei okay was für eine demütigung vom
eigenen mann so abgewertet zu werden
thomas hätte viel eher und vor allem
einfühlsamer mit ihr reden müssen der
typ links denkt sich so es geht
überhaupt nicht das geht überhaupt nicht
nein er will müssen wir können uns mal
wir können jetzt mal wirklich mal die
wahrheit die beim schopf packen heute
wir können jetzt mal sagen woran es
liegt es ist diese farbe die macht mich
wirklich einfach aggressiv was ich kann
diesen allein der farbton zögert mich
schon gesteigert dass man den in den
haaren hat thomas verdient als
angestellter kfz-meister 2600 euro netto
im monat
ich dachte erst er rechtsanwalt
arbeitest du beim geheimdienst er ist
bisher ein bisschen genauer schmidt als
wir das ist nicht mehr klar was das
scheiße
na ja meine eltern streiten sich ja
meine meine mutter hat jetzt sich
letztes jahr gefärbt und seitdem seitdem
kann ich dir einfach nicht mehr
anschauen
dazu kommt auch noch das geschrieben und
gedruckt als aber ich kann mein showbiz
ich kann manchmal einen sagen leute
dieses mädel hier auf der rechten seite
die arbeitskollege von der tochter ist
die mit der der vater später
ihr wisst schon heute keine knappheit
quasi den knackarsch würde ich sagen zu
einem normalen arbeitsplatz werden alle
so
aber das so als zahnarzthelferin beim
zahnarzt du fängst du an auf einmal dem
zahnarzt zu erzählen ja oh meine eltern
streiten sich die rechte des und
behandelter 5 und 5 also männliche
version von mir kann man nichts sagen
der typ ist auch einfach ist hat was
weiß ich doch dass tamara müssen wir mit
namen ansprechen
tamara was das für eine aussage guck
mich mal an wie perfekt ich aussehe
per se schon mal kritisch okay wenn man
dann aber auch de facto nicht perfekt
aussieht weil wer welcher mensch schon
perfekt aus um so kritischer
ich gehe hier auch ab und zu joggen
leute aber ich bin ja nicht auf die idee
gekommen dass mich das perfekt aussehen
lässt als er ich hätte einfach ich hätte
viel mehr erfolg bei frauen haben können
hier etwas sagen müssen
cook michalski joggen sie perfekt aus
da ist ja auch noch echt süß geht's aber
nicht janáceks so sie erzählt von den
problemen ihrer kollegin es weiter also
okay du hast kein problem geschildert
liebe kolleginnen aber halt kurz ok
kommen wir mal zu den wesentlichen
sachen ich sie perfekt aus ok ich will
dein vater ja das ist doch immer gesagt
meine mama hat ihre ausbildung
abgebrochen wir haben kein geld mehr
papa verdient hat meinen vater für den
2006 euro netto wie steht ihr helfen mir
rechtsanwalt mit röntgenblick erkannt
hat kann man übrigens auch hier noch mal
in ihrer frisur sehen dass der vater
2600 euro netto verdient als
angestellter kfz meister also wirklich
wird das jetzt hier in der system nicht
erkennt dass er komplett beendet und
leute man muss doch noch mal sagen ich
bin ich peter zwegat aber so rein
schulden technisch was ist auf der
einnahmenseite 2600 euro netto
eingestellter kfz meister was es auf der
schulden seite 31.000 schulden nicht
euro könnte jetzt alles ein äpfel birnen
ich weiß es nicht aber 31.000
so dass jetzt herr am ende gibt's
nämlich wirklich okay also wir sind
bisschen weiter in dem video und der
vater hat mir darunter im park gedreht
ja er hat auch sein auto mitten im park
abgestellt da muss ich mal kurz fragen
was bei was ist da los
es ist ein park mitten im park der da
kommt wie wie kommt er über 3 wie auch
immer auf jeden fall kamera nutzt die
situation um sich mal eben in
natürlicher pose in der nähe seines
wagens zu positionieren und zwar
ungefähr so weiter was moment moment
moment ich hoffe mich gehört aber egal
sind sie sind es ist ein fucking hunde
oder sieben menschen knüpfen wir zu
kennen lernen anderen oder wie hier
warum wichtiger warum fressen auch nicht
in 3d ist doch ziemlich machen die hunde
auch gut so wirklich überhaupt nichts
gut alter da tritt mir alles um david
thomas auf den ältesten trick der welt
rein das befüllen der älteste trick der
welt einfach so tun als wenn man ag und
man
ich bin kein mensch
träume sind okay supertoll haben sie
jetzt beschnüffelt schön
damit ist auch die frage des titels
beantwortet leute frau betrügen für
knackarsch vorgeschlagen das wiederum
könnte man kann aber nicht an der stelle
ausmacht gut